going on I like to party Jesus honey
this is unwaxed
the Sophia and Sistine Salon can we just
become best friends
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters Sophia and
Sistine
first thing I'm looking at is you're
wearing a rock choker or not a rock
choker it's a crystal you have two
Crystal chokers yeah that makes sense
yeah I do well it's actually no no it is
rock and Crystal do you have a toe ring
as well and a nose piercing are you
drinking kombucha what is going on okay
I was influenced an influencer was
wearing this set I thought it was really
cute and I also just like the good
energy that it kind of brings and maybe
yeah obviously I know everything is
mental and I know that I feel you know
when you say I I'm obsessed with numbers
I've been seeing like four four four
everywhere and so I always say that that
my angel numbers those are what Angels
what does this have to do with the Rocco
but I'm saying that I don't think that
there are actual angel numbers coming at
me I think it's all mental so I'm
thinking oh yeah this rock is giving me
a lot of Weird Al it's like you
literally went into a Mall fountain
picked that up out of the fountain it's
not cute I like it I get what you're
going for but actually I just ordered
you something similar to that for
Christmas then why you
why are you back because that one needs
to go in the garbage no they're it's a
cute set together do you guys like it
it's like oh man the red one's worse no
it's not let me see it again no show the
camera
comment section I Like It by the way
it's a cute little set
thank you all right let's let's go into
our waxiness you're just penis what did
you not do sleep last night why are you
shitty on me I woke up and chose
violence today so strap it it's a long
episode all right also I sound like a
man but I will get into why for a walks
and Wayne of the week which is basically
our highs and lows of the week do you
want to start or should I yeah I can
start I feel like mine's probably a
little simpler because you can kind of
jump into yours but my wax of the week
is that I got to relax this last weekend
with my boyfriend and
in uh Palm Beach so I didn't do what you
did which was the total opposite what
did you guys do yeah
online set walks had fun dinners and
drinks it must be nice it was great okay
I I had this debate with my girlfriend
um actually I guess it's not a debate
but an agreement it is so nice to just
drink wine at night and have that buzz I
think the best type of drunk is wine
drunk and after having that experience
it's just you want to know why why
because sorry one drunk makes you a
little frisky
no but I'll tell you why because Tequila
Makes You sloppy vodka makes you gross
but wine you're you're feeling yourself
your body's buzzing it's warm you feel
sexy but you're bloated you don't even
know you're bloated from the wine you're
like fine being bloody you're fine you
literally I couldn't amputate my arm I'm
like thank you but it truly is the worst
hangover so it's almost like the reward
isn't worth the bet the I think so no is
it I think so reward pain whatever
um but yeah no it's really nice and I
think also it's nice not having a plan
to go out sometimes because I I do like
going out I I do yeah but when you're
having a kind of a wholesome weekend
even though I did just say I was
drinking
um and it just it felt no you were
calling me you were saying you're going
for bike ride I was getting facetimes
from her at like 2 A.M well I'll explain
later I know we went to bike rides it
was just really cute it was really sweet
and then my Wayne was I I feel like
people have it sometimes but I woke up
just I think it was
Sunday morning feeling horrible and I
realized that I just woke up having
major anxiety yeah I could tell you know
I the night before I was super agitated
like anything anyone said I was really
sensitive to it I knew it was coming on
because something that you always do
when you're about to get a major anxiety
attack is throw a whole lot of SASS and
a whole lot of eye rolls at everyone I
know people think and I'm like why are
you getting so upset you're about to get
your time
something's coming no but I felt like
just really agitated and sustain I
remember I like said something kind of
snarky and you call me I'd be like well
[ __ ]
little lady one of these I didn't of
course like when I'm in my mind said
like I don't think it's wrong but then I
realized later on but I woke up the next
day just like
off and it wasn't
you know when you have anxiety and you
wake up the first thing you feel is just
kind of this dread and you kind of feel
your body buzzing and not controlled
like I knew that if I was around anybody
I'd just kind of switch off it's
actually a scary feeling because you
truly think that you can't control your
emotions in that moment like you don't
know what you're gonna say you can't
help it and my my anxiety problems I
wake up and I'll think about things that
I can't do all day I was thinking about
things I have done I'll regret like I'll
say the things I'm doing right now like
writing a book I'll be like why the hell
am I pursuing this I can't do this and
then I also think another part of
anxiety is you you and I are planners
for our day we're like okay we're gonna
wake up at this time eat go to the gym
we have our whole schedule mapped out
and so we always do that the morning of
and the night before just because we're
neurotic like that and when you have
that plan for your day and you're
sitting in bed already knowing that
you're not gonna do it so now you're
even more upset with yourself yeah
because you're like [ __ ] my anxiety
won't even let me do things I want to do
and yeah completely and you know
actually this is probably if anyone has
this where you wake up and you just feel
like you cannot get out of your head you
know that you're gonna snap up you're
about to pop off and you really nothing
is helping you actually two things did
help me it was one admitting to
everybody and saying hey you guys I'm
actually feeling really shitty today
like I can't my emotions are just out of
all time high I feel really anxious and
just give me a little bit of space like
let me I'm not if I take [ __ ] out on you
I'm so sorry like I just know that I
don't mean it I'm just I need to be
alone a little bit and then
um Sarah who like works at the house
with us she I was telling her that I
wasn't feeling great and you know she
actually stepped me out of it I was just
gonna go on like a long therapeutic walk
just get out of my head and Sarah goes
so what's wrong with you and I go true I
just don't feel great she goes are you
sick and I go no she has
are you
ugly I go
are you ugly I'm like I mean I I guess
not I I mean thank you but uh no I guess
not but then she kept saying she goes
the one's making you anxious that's true
sometimes you need to work I go yeah
yeah she goes do you have a boyfriend I
go yeah do you have a family yeah what's
wrong with you I was like
that's awesome
that moment I was like I
[ __ ] put me in my place in
perspective because you went on a
humbling walk after that I did I
actually did and this is the thing when
you have anxiety and your your thoughts
and your emotions are so out of whack
and you feel like you can't control it
sometimes getting that little
perspective going okay what do you have
okay you have a family but I do have to
say it depends on who it's coming from
because if I said that to you you'd
probably back that's actually very true
I know I do believe that that's true it
has to be from an outside source that
you can't get mad at because I yes yes I
is it's true though don't you feel like
you take advice more from people you
don't know yes like if you told me
something right now that was we had
someone behind the screen right now if
you told me something that was just very
impactful in life versus when she would
tell me I think I would take it from you
more not about no way no way
just because I feel like it's you know
when you're with your family or people
around you so often like some you
obviously appreciate their advice but
there's something that's more impactful
and deeper when it's coming from someone
else
quotes I remember the most are the ones
from random dinner parties where I'd sit
some yeah like next to someone I go wow
like oh yeah build calluses work hard
like get your hands in the dirt and
that's how you're gonna make it and it's
just yeah so having that perspective
change maybe talking to someone else
maybe if it's your girlfriend maybe it's
your boyfriend maybe it's someone that
you know doesn't judge you but knows
that they can kind of like reel you in a
little bit definitely do that maybe it's
the valet guy who knows it could be
anybody anybody Santa Claus since it's
the holidays right now
let me try to make a joke all right just
to not land I'm Gonna Roll right past
that one my wax and weight of the week
oh my God okay so actually for the first
time in podcast history I don't have a
Wayne
and I want to complain about everything
actually I do have a way and I just
thought of your necklaces that's so mean
that's my way my wax my Instagram no
one's complimented me on these yet I
told you guys on the last episode that I
was going to Miami
I needed to let loose Sophia and
Scarlett my whole family basically
always calling me the boring one that I
don't loosen up that I don't go out
you called yourself literally the last
two episodes the boring one that doesn't
yeah but I don't like to hear it from
you guys it's different what I said
about myself you are a little bit boring
I know and I don't ever drink I don't
loose enough so I told you guys I was
headed to Miami for the weekend and I
will give you a recap and let's just say
my wax is the weekend yeah y'all
Tina my Alter Ego came out to her
fullest guys look at her nails don't
look at my nails I got Miami Nails I'm
sorry listen I fully converted to like
the ratchet lifestyle that is Miami and
I loved every minute of it yeah I went
out four nights in a row four days in a
row I drank I rallied I didn't sleep
from Thursday to Sunday literally
Thursday on Monday I went out Thursday
Friday Saturday I had a train I was
gonna take a very depressing train ride
home hungover on Sunday and I said you
know what cancel that train Mr train
conductor I'm staying another night I
was like why not I got some left in my
system I'll go out again it was so much
fun yeah and just being in that
environment
knowing that I can do it I was so in my
head I was like Jesus Christ it's not
that bad I told you that I know and you
you had a great time and your level of
going out was when it went from zero to
100 I mean you barely have a glass of
wine at dinner like she doesn't do
anything
I will tell you this I don't have I
didn't have one cocktail I only did
shots as heinous I literally what it
looked like in the morning because I
would stay up till four you know what I
looked like in the morning but I looked
in the mirror my face was so swollen it
looked like green yellow I was like oh
my God I looked like the Mucinex guy in
the commercials oh that's why I was like
bloated I was like oh Jesus did you have
like an ice roller or something ice
rolling my face all day did it again the
next night I heard actually a good hack
to get over hangovers was dipping your
face into a nice Bowl I should have done
anything for a bucket of ice water I was
taking Ginger shots carrot shots I was
just trying so what did you do each day
well you can give maybe like a brief
Thursday
I went to a rave
that was a mistake that was too much
that was you know I went into the deep
end with that one but it was fun I ran
into some old friends from La that was
great Friday I was very hungover so I
just took it easy at a dinner which
ended up turning into a club so that was
my easy night I didn't drink that night
no I did
Saturday was my hard day I went hard I
went to three different locations I was
I literally went to bed this is how
Saturday went I went to bed I woke up my
feet were covered in sand no
recollection of going to a beach I was
covered in bruises and blisters and
there was booze next to me and I was
like oh my it was just
eventful it was fun I think I you know
what's so fun is when you go to bed
your memory is a little bit blurry a
little bit hazy
and
everyone starts sending you videos of
the night before
yeah yeah that's not fun it literally
felt like the movie Hangover at the very
end of the credits when they see the
camera roll
I didn't get down from an elevated
surface for three hours straight good
workout
my legs were so toned I was sore Nails
in your dancing on the table oh my God
hours yeah yeah so I was just you know
living my best life but something I love
about the Miami culture is the people
watching
yeah
you find my characters there I tried to
like
pull out the smallest little dresses and
just try to because I don't want
anything like that so I was raiding
Scarlett's closet decided to dress up
very Ops than she normally like she
wears like sexy outfits but normally
they're classy these were just like
Sophia's like you look like you're
wearing lingerie it was lingerie if you
want to look look at her Instagram posts
I swear the most conservative one there
it was crazy the girls I mean I was just
standing there in um like first of all
the confidence
where did you get it because it's just I
don't know how they can be in a napkin
and call it a now I think people are
just that's the environment people go
into it going okay I'm gonna wear the
tightest shortest most revealing outfit
and just kind of own it because everyone
and no one's like perfect there I feel
like here everything is I mean look I do
think Miami can kind of get like a
little bit instagramable type thing
where people are always trying to like
everyone looks like Flappy Bird with the
lips and the in the filler what is it Dr
Miami isn't everyone gets procedures
there is that Dr Miami yeah that's the
thing everyone also kind of looks the
same so they go to the same plastic so
yeah yeah yeah it's very sign me up
because they look like they're having a
great time I loved it I want to go back
it happened that weekend that was just
like a specific standout well I ran into
my friend Brielle yeah Brielle Biermann
I love her and I met her whole friend
group which they're just so nice and
having them all just sort of take me in
right and you know I was like the new
kid in the group and they were just
being so nice and it was so much fun
like did I feel like you just needed a
reset because I think you forgot that
you can do it and you can go out of it
fine that's the lesson in this you guys
last episode I was really down in the
dumps I was so sad I felt like I was
stuck in this hole for a few months not
even admitting how upset I was and then
just do something to make you
uncomfortable pull yourself out of your
comfort zone and maybe you might just
like snap out of it have fun prove to
yourself that you can do something that
you're constantly telling yourself you
couldn't and I know it sounds silly as
just going out and letting loose but
that's a big deal for me yeah so just
try they're just like relaxing and you
know what it is is we had we did debate
with you Mom and I in the car when we
picked you up from the station is that
you're like oh but it's Miami that's why
I did I'm like yeah you can let loose
but you can let loose anywhere if you
wanted to you just need to just you know
relax about it I also think it depends
on the group oh yeah it's because it's a
group thing too that was a great group
of people I think it would have been a
totally different experience would you
go back for like a birthday or your
bachelorette party I'm already trying to
go back I know I yeah love it I know you
should well when we moved to New York
that's just gonna be very easy jump Skip
and hop away I'm 100 doing my
bachelorette there yeah I'm throwing it
I know you are you and Scarlet are just
gonna be a deadly combo you're gonna
cheat on your fiance let's don't say
that that's just that's horrible
make it my mission oh no I'm oh yeah
yours is going to be very very very fun
but it's gonna be super thought out
mine's gonna be no because you're too
methodical you're too organized so it's
gonna be like okay in three minutes we
need to move locations hey which is fine
it's gonna be perfect anything and
everything you want is gonna happen
there I won't miss you know what it is
I'm not gonna miss a beat like
everything that you can't miss I will
have there this is gonna be a little
messy like you're gonna wake up
engagement ring I'll have a backuping
these I'll have like backups for you I'm
like okay you forgot your engagement
ring I bought another one in case you
forgot it you uh you need to you're
hungover you have to Rally the New
Mexico oh it's okay Ivy drop this right
here like I'm gonna be ready for that
moment but you know you got to also
experience it not in the probably more
no I'm not the normal way but I guess
the stereotypical way of going because a
lot of people have their routine of like
you did go to live in those places but
you got to see newer smaller places that
people probably oh my God yes and can I
just say
I'm a good dancer no yeah I know you're
gonna say that that's why I said this
yeah your limbs are a little you look
you're a little I do look like the what
is it I I call you like the dancing cart
she doesn't look like the inflatable
Tube Man oh yeah car dealership yes
for people thought I looked good dancing
is there someone saw that specifically
yeah every person in the club oh okay
okay was there one place that you would
definitely go back to that you like
really liked I just wish I could go back
in time and do it all over again I was
showing Dad we have a very open
relationship with our parents yeah so I
was showing them every video of me was
like taking shots and on tables and
having a great time and I was showing
Mom and Dad and Dad Whispers in my ear
he goes why the hell would you leave and
I was like true I know yeah he gets it I
know I know definitely much more upbeat
than Palm Beach so fun I thought that
you had a good time you know it's fun
also visiting Scarlett since she's there
and I mean now we get to see her this
week but yes but uh you know I was
actually thinking about
this today because your boyfriend keeps
hounding me about what to get you for
Christmas and I'm just as confused as he
is I don't even know what to get you let
alone guide him to know what to do I
actually think the worst thing about
holidays is gift giving it's so I'm
sorry I hate it no because I hate it
you're bad at receiving gifts yeah
every Christmas she's not happy with me
shitty gifts a Squatty Potty isn't like
a nice gift to God I got you other stuff
too name it what a boxers with Maples
face no I get you like really cute
clothes like come on you know I do you
do those are great I receive a very well
I like everything that you give me not
those gifts but
I'm bad at also giving gifts because I'm
bad at thinking for other people like
what they would actually want I'll tell
you why I'm good at gifts
because I have a Notes app in my phone
for about six months before Christmas
if Sophia was like oh the necklace
you're wearing is really cute I want to
start like finding where those are I
will literally write it down in my notes
so that for Christmas like for Scarlett
I got her this matching crop top pant
set that she mentioned two months ago
that she wanted so I got her that [ __ ]
you remember so they go oh my God you're
such a good memory you're so thoughtful
like I know I am still trying to think
of you and Scarlet I love giving gifts I
hate like I don't want anything but I
just love it I don't want anything I
also don't want to give it anything I
just want to think about it that's super
sweet it's I can't I'm good at writing
letters if you need me to write a really
nice letter that'll make you cry got it
yeah you wrote all of the letters I
write every letter like that's what I
love to do but it's difficult especially
yeah being in a relationship I'm trying
to think of what to get him too I'm
gonna get him some slippers I'm not
getting him slippers what he's gonna use
those a lot some nice Birkins I thought
like workout clothes for a second
because he loves to work out a lot and
he will use it every day that's
something that I would like things that
you don't actually buy for yourself that
you need like a matching
two side socks with it and you know and
then I thought of something like teeth
whitening strips like things that you
wouldn't Splurge for yourself 100 yeah
but things I Rec I said it to Mom and
she's like no you gotta go nicer I was
like oh God Jennifer I know she makes it
so difficult she actually is tough to
she's the hardest person to get as far
as your parents yeah that's that's a
no-go I would say for guys though if
you're shopping for him I wouldn't do
clothes because every time I bought a
guy like a jacket or a pair of shoes I
just said workout clothes and you just
no but I mean like a nice jacket or a
pair of cool shoes like they never wear
it yeah they have their Style and what
they like and you just waste all your
money yeah you get shoes wait what else
would you do I've done cologne I love a
cologne if like I can give you guys 100
racks for cologne like I'm trying to
think like nice one Tom for tobacco
vanilla I mean it's like okay so save
rate he likes
sneakers just get them like a cool pair
of like New Balance they'll always wear
that you know something like that or
something statues something that he
already has but just in a different
wacky color I think also what we've done
is picture frames I really no it's so
nice it's not you've done it you've did
it actually like not even that longer I
thought I was ashamed
no if you've got like a really beautiful
frame and then you put a cute photo of
the two of you guys like that's really
cute and then you write it like maybe on
the back of the photograph a letter what
are the weirdest gifts that no are
significant other but what do you no I
want to ask you like Sophia I don't know
no what about girls what to get girls
yeah why are we
we can't miss girls I can feel like guys
listen to this too we have like 50 male
listeners I mean bras if you think about
it how old are your brothers no I'm
gonna see this question how old are your
brothers Sistine
um no they're pretty right no I never
recycle it I like I change them up
they're pretty old is what she said
that was a long answer to say they're
pretty good no I don't want my like
boyfriend or whoever I'm dating to get
me a bra that's kind of hot though
that's yeah that's a Valentine's Day
gift getting like a cute like lingerie
is that oh like you got me that like
unless you're unless it's uh you could
dress up as this unless Richard Gere and
Jennifer
um what's her name Julia Roberts and
he's getting me like this long Ball
Ground that's red and a huge diamond
necklace that's the only clothing I need
but so you want to be a stripper
girls is headsets like headphones I
think everyone's really into those like
those app ones they're really expensive
though yeah jewelry like maybe like a
cute earring like little Hoops yeah
Everyone likes like a little huggie
nothing you can't go wrong with the ho
hoop no girls will love it perfume
honestly you know what actually I would
say if you're confused go on Tick Tock
and just look up gifts for her there's
like you can see every single girl gift
that girls are obsessed with maybe she
doesn't even have it like oh this
perfume has been really popular girls
like let me just get it for her I'm also
just a big re-gifter
yeah or or I'll go into my room look at
like my products or my perfumes and if I
like it I'll just buy them the same one
yeah because that's easier you know it's
good you know I don't I don't want gifts
I only like gift cards I don't want
anything for Christmas other than gift
cards you know why because I don't like
when people buy things for me I want to
just choose what I want to buy but I
think that's like kind of like The Best
of Both Worlds you get a gift card from
Sephora oh my God perfect I know exactly
I need to refill myself give me a cash
in an envelope that's it just give me
money that's it just give me a hundred
dollars for two months that's all that
it does no it's fine I feel like as I
get older I'm realizing that
I'm not wanting the things I used to
want when I was younger obviously I'm
like yeah I'm not asking my mom for like
Barbie's dream house but
um speaking of Barbie I just went on a
full-on bender looking at every Barbie
movie on Amazon Prime why
you bring up Barbie Swan Lake to me once
a month what are you here because you're
making it seem like it's weird that I
just said that yeah we love it it's
different when I said I brought up one
movie and you said you went on a bender
not watching them just looking at all
the trailers like every song okay no and
I just forgot how nostalgic it is so you
don't want a Barbie for Christmas hell
no what do you want then I want like a
gym membership that's enough Barnes
Noble gift card done Amazon gift card
that's what you're getting a bookshelf
something like that but um yeah I have
very gifted things actually no I've
never re-gifted anything but I've gone
like pretty bad gifts before
like just just not one no I mean I
wouldn't say what you mean from like
significant others well just from
friends it's not just significant others
like okay what's so bad that you've
gotten I've gone
one of uh one of my friends gave me a
Therapy book
like basically I had to chill out it was
like it was like how to calm down you
need help read this it was so I was like
it was sweet because you know obviously
the intention behind it but I mean I'm
like in the holidays I'm unwrapping
paper it says get help getting humbled
during the holidays yeah okay you know
it could help me but like things I think
um I've gone to a cookbook full of just
um hamburgers you don't even eat burgers
no okay there I mean no I do but like I
don't make them all right there's like
hundreds and hundreds of photos of
burgers like someone gave me um body
soap and I was like are you trying to
say that just body soap smell just one
jar of body soap and I was like I don't
smell all right I'm very hygienic so
what is this oh yeah yeah oh it's like
giving someone here's a toothbrush I'm
like oh well I got this gift and I kind
of thought it was like like a joke gift
because I'm not really sure what I would
do with it I've never talked about this
character in my life but I've gone a
glass sculpture of Snoopy
I remember that and I I and it was it
was super sweet
but I I didn't get it like I I don't
care about Snoopy like because your
bedside table just a ceramic two foot
Snoopy I just like do you remember we
used to grow up having like like mommies
to keep a ton of these just like those
glass animals and little sculptures and
like horses mom used to keep them
I was a collector as a child that was my
collection how random you know what's
the scariest toy for me was those little
Russian doll things that open up and it
gets smaller and smaller I like those I
didn't like them I thought that freaked
me out they are they called Russian
dolls yeah I think so yeah not in like
those or dolls in general I I always
broke every single glass sculpture we
got one like Little Pony ones yeah
fell off she ripped all the legs off my
arms not on purpose I wasn't just
ripping off legs why are you even in my
collection anyway part of a mine Sophia
it was not your collection you collected
pennies in quarters
you collected Cornish from every steak
no it was that it was that the quarters
like every single state I could get and
I freaking did it twice over I feel like
I just unlocked a new memory I totally
forgot you used to collect eraser
shavings too
so don't come for me in my glass figure
all right when you get them big enough
in a little basket they get really soft
and fun to play with
um you didn't you were just so what we
used to have in there remember we saw
like giant posters in our bedroom of
like just the most random people yeah we
get them from like j14 magazine yeah
well I I think I was normal I had like
Justin Bieber and all these like what do
you think I'm not normal you want photos
of just kittens everywhere on your side
of the wall it was freaky it was just
like kind of like on your ceiling your
stand the Naked Brothers Band oh it was
a cat or Nate wolf there's no I thought
he was the sexiest person ever and now
looking back like
what was I thinking I mean it's kind of
funny it's kind of it's kind of came
back a little bit yeah
okay okay
um but I think that's just point blank
like I just give him money
[Laughter]
you know what I look forward to the
holidays are sort of like birthdays yeah
because you always get that one
curveball of a text from a certain
someone that is waiting for a holiday
just to creep right back into your life
oh yeah whether it's a side piece an old
hookup
are you an ex-boyfriend a girlfriend
we're we act like it's such an innocent
move on our part of their apartment oh
they're just being nice yeah it's a
funny it's intentional it's so
intentional because I do it oh you no
it's it's what you do it's you do a
Halloween you do it on Christmas I if
let's say if I was people on Halloween
no happy Halloween when I was single and
I want an excuse to talk to someone I
would find any freaking holiday I'd be
like hey happy dolly dolly whatever it's
called or happy uh Happy Columbus Day oh
my God like
happy Presidents Day happy Saint Patrick
hope you're doing really well we should
catch up soon it's true it's such a like
little sneaky move so horrible I can't
wait to hear from all of you guys I'm so
excited it just kind of it does like
kind of flip-flop you you're like oh
[ __ ] what do I say birthdays are tough
because you kind of should answer unless
you don't know I mean you don't have to
answer but uh when it comes to like
Christmas like that's also one you kind
of should answer and it just opens a can
of worms it's dangerous
but I love worms open that can right up
yeah put them in a blender I'm slurping
it down I am here for it I love hearing
here I know last time I was actually in
the studio
we were talking about can you be friends
with your ex
actly everyone said no and I still
believe there's there's a way no yes I
will answer you know we also talked
about the text and all of that we also
talked about in the studio and we said
it's totally we were literally fully
serious eating like it's so fun to say
happy birthday to your ex like you
should we I actually believed that and
I'm like wait what am I saying like you
know what I feel like it's until your
current boyfriend gets mad
yeah because if you were single it'd be
fine but I feel like every time I'm in a
relationships online if I'm in a
relationship if I'm in a relationship
yeah and I'm texting my ex happy
birthday it's wrong yeah but if I'm not
in a relationship I'm not hurting anyone
no yeah of course
I don't get an answer I'm hurting myself
oh no I think the holidays in general I
just you know holiday parties when you
see your family members you sometimes
will run into those you know I hate
about holiday parties how many highs you
have to give to your whole family I feel
like I'm just like pessimistic couldn't
really use French because literally the
last episode I was saying how I hate
holiday parties and it's stressful and
you were dogging on me about what are
you talking about it's so fun so what
what's going on I don't know I'm
thinking about it more and more now now
that we have to hit I think it's the
rock around your neck it's giving you
negatives it's giving me balance
just like those Hoops are for your head
those are the biggest Hoops I've ever
seen comes back from Miami
on her ear I bought I bought you guys I
bought this in Miami you you don't look
like yourself I'm a little thank you
yeah I didn't like myself before I did
ah she's boring look at she does phone
case it's just all of it's like you're
bedazzled right now this is just not you
this is such a change I got silver tips
on my fingers looks like I fingered the
Tin Man it's like not did taking 18
shots alter your brain I actually think
it did because I made some very
questionable decisions oh
want to talk about that stunning
do you know that for a second I love it
I'm good at it do it okay you're so bad
at accidentally you have to say the line
what's the first line what's your chunk
of choice
what's your drink of choice
and Negroni
spagliatives with Prosecco in it
see that wasn't bad I felt like you're
trying to give me like seduce eyes and
well she was seductive in it yeah but
were you trying to be seductive no
sustain you're my sister why would I
give you seductive eyes you know what
speaking of this Sophia told me the
other day that she said she said to me
I look like I'm a bad kisser yeah
tell if someone's a good kisser not just
by looking lover I just don't think
you're good you're bad you give me open
mouth fives
open mouth Vibes like you go in with an
open mouth I feel like you're
tight-lipped like no I use the lips but
but now I'm in my head about it and I
hate you I've been told I'm good then
you're brilliant I mean no someone told
who was this I think our cousin Ryan I'm
like oh yeah I've been told I was a good
kisser and he goes You know guys just
say that to like no yeah oh so now you
never know now I don't know I think I am
I'm just gonna say I am and think I am
so I remember when we were young we used
to probably you are pissing on a spoon
do you we practice kissing a spoon I
used to watch his YouTube videos of how
to make out that's remember yeah oh yeah
it was like how to kiss God I I took
that to heart Scarlett's by far the
worst I have to say oh yeah yeah for
sure she gives bad kissing Vibes you
know what it is I'm a perfectionist so I
have to be good no really like I I need
to see this is why I don't think you're
good because you're sure why would you
say because you're so technical that
you're not in the moment that you're
thinking about how to be perfect first
and look hot I'm gonna stand there going
I had turned right left
hell no the fact that I'm a
perfectionist and I'm like methodical
about it I think okay I gotta go there
oh then I gotta go here oh now we're
going to go that's making me nauseous
does it ruin if someone's a bad kisser
on the first date a few yeah I don't I
think it's one of those things that you
can't just
teach them over time yeah and I do think
if there's some sort of
dance that just flows perfectly
organically then that says something
yeah it was the funniest thing I've ever
seen was that guy it was that video
um one of those you know those YouTube
uh channels that do those experiments
with people where they go okay um this
guy that's never kissed before is gonna
kiss like 10 girls or they have like
they have an astrologist guess people
zodiac signs without like knowing them
or things like that or tell pick the
people together that they're dating but
I remember this one guy and it was about
I think he's never kissed before it was
the most uncomfortable thing I've ever I
know who you're talking about you know
that guy yeah I think he didn't he run
away bless him yeah no but um you should
kiss me I need practice apparently
speaking of kissing and maybe not
kissing is I'm watching the new too hot
to handle oh yeah there's a new one yeah
it just came out
you know I really always I've always
wanted to be on one of those stupid
shows I've we've always said we wanted
to be on it but didn't want to be on it
is it good anyone cute yeah oh yeah
great cast such a reality like
you're the new Love Island can't get
into it I've probably watched every
single dating show fuckboy Island I
should make one too ought to handle you
should love Island
he was I would you should like make one
I know because
me as the lead I want to be a host of a
dating show I would no not the host
Creator no I I want to but I'm saying I
would love to be a host and Creator no
no you can't be the host because I'm
going to be no no no no no no yeah why
would you say that I want to be the host
no but I'm more of a hosting face stop
it you are such no you look like you no
no okay Sistine who is she who knows
because okay you brought in a study
let's hear your study oh okay
um be a little eager no I know okay so
we actually tried to do this last week
and um I'm really into this new topic so
you guys if you don't like this topic I
usually say let me know but don't let me
know because I actually I'm going to
keep this forever if you don't like it
fall asleep now because it's about
sleeping it's actually about dreams so I
you know of course I'm a researcher so I
love to look up things anything I like
to figure out why things happen the way
they are so we're doing this little
thing called Sophia's studies
[Laughter]
Sophia's studies
[Laughter]
that's so uncomfortable yeah take it
away okay cool I hope you guys watched
that no you're making me sweat okay
so I remember last episode I was talking
about lucid dreams right
lucid dreams are really cool they kind
of freaked me out but I'm into them
um and also one thing I realized about
lucid dreams that are really scary is
the sleep paralysis that you can get
from lucid dreaming where you see like
Monsters Yeah so basically your body's
turned off and your mind's on and your
eyes are open and you can see the things
in real time like ghosts or whatever I
can't move I know you like that stuff
you're kind of Twisted a little bit
thank you I know she like reads books
about Richard Speck and every murderer
in serial killer fall asleep this is why
you shouldn't be the host of anything
including a dating show why because all
these serial killers are like love guys
and they like kill the people they're on
dates with why would you be the host of
that I'm like I read romance novels so
you say I should start a show called
like dating serial killers I really
don't know they like try to like get
back on the market and
they tried a new Leaf they're not trying
to kill anymore they're trying to find
love
that's a good idea that's really not a
good idea right now okay so I'm just
gonna say some facts and I think you I
think it'd be kind of interesting
because I didn't know so 95 of people
forget their dreams waking up but we
have at least four to six streams a
night do you know what 46 4 to 16 dreams
a night and then our most Vivid ones
occur around 4am I thought there was
gonna be more than that and you know
what's interesting is that I realize
when I wake up in the middle of the
night like at three or two you know when
your body suddenly wakes up when I go
back to sleep I feel like that's what my
dreams are the most Vivid yeah you know
maybe that's why maybe because we're a
little bit more awake and our minds
awake but okay and did you know 12 of
people dream in black and white
how interesting is that that's weird
I've never dreamed in black and white I
think that they only dream in black and
white how is it do
they're obviously not seeing black and
white during the day like why well if
you guys if anyone watching the streams
in black and white shoot us a message we
gotta talk so they realize even dreaming
like when they analyzed at least 50 000
dreams all of them are associated with
negative feelings more than positive
ones like it's rare to have like a
really positive dream like a lot of the
things that maybe it's good some of them
are positive but they're slightly
associated with some anxiety which is
kind of sad maybe it's because all of
our fears come out
and I I think because people are very
stressed most of the time yeah when you
go to bed stress and then you dream
stress and then this is also when I
didn't know this men dream more about
men not sexually than women
really yeah like men have dreams about
men we confirm this
like do you man behind the camera
yes okay for some reason girls dream
more about 50 50. okay girls and guys
but guys end up dreaming a lot more
frequently about their guy friends or
guys
it's a bromance it's a romance
okay so this is Scott this is I think
something we can kind of dive into 23 of
people have dreamed about their partner
cheating on them or having an affair
themselves
yeah but do you dream it does that count
as cheating that's that's that's right I
feel like some people would say yes I
know so I was reading about this a
little bit more and that's why people
when they wake up they get really angry
at their partner or they feel really
guilty after doing it but I love doing
that I I have remembered
actually I feel like this happened maybe
two months ago where I woke up I thought
my boyfriend had cheated on me and I was
so mad at him the whole day and this
poor boy I was like YouTube
right because how do you it's so crazy
how like real dreams can get and they
can really just mess with your emotions
but especially those are the only way
you can explore that opportunity with
anyone in the world but I've had shitty
dreams
and I've woken up okay but it's only
when it comes to that stuff that I wake
up and I I still threw out feelings no
that's just us wanting to find any
reason to get mad at our boyfriend no
yes no no no but okay so don't get mad
at someone because of a dream like he's
got no shot
teach throm okay so I think I wanted to
kind of go into top things that people
dream about and what they mean okay so
if anyone has like a dream that they
haven't they've been having frequently
these are like the top ones so if you're
being chased in your dream and you feel
like every time you get chased you just
cannot get out of the situation I've
been chased a lot you know like as fast
as you go as many corners as you cut you
just cannot get away it's associated
with anxiety that things are catching up
to you in real life
I just I pray yeah which feels like so
things are kind of like in the
background that are coming up to you and
you just feel like you can't get rid of
it okay
um teeth falling out yes this one I get
a lot
um Can represent some sort of personal
loss or feelings of inadequacy
just kidding I don't go that way I've
never dreamed out of my life no it's sad
I I you know what teeth you do say that
you had that a lot but I feel like no I
didn't I don't care just kidding I've
had this one flying but this is more
when I was younger now yeah that's like
a young one this is like personal
freedom control the and um unconscious
abilities that you can possess falling
I've had that so many times where I've
kicked myself in the middle of the night
when you actually like your body
splashes up because I feel like you're
actually following so this is we've lost
control in some aspect of our life that
needs to be identified possibly a
metaphor for a need to be grounded or
lost touch with reality
foreign
do you think it is but like how would
how would they know this whoever's doing
the research on this
how would you know that that's the
detail that that's what it means it's so
specific I will I feel like they're I
don't know okay then this one's kind of
interesting seeing old friends so these
childhood friends that you no longer
associate emerge in your dreams to show
you that the past is still relevant
dreams commonly resurface past
experiences if change is needed in your
life
so yeah I was not going to ask you what
dreams you've had the most frequently
and I can help look it up and tell you
what your problem is
maybe the teeth falling one was already
answered actually like I haven't been
remembering my dreams lately
really yeah I'll tell you what my
horrible ones have been recently were
the most frequent one I got is
I can't talk I'll open my mouth and I
feel myself talking the way I talk but
no words come out and no one's listening
and it's really annoying like I can't
control that would be my dream
for me to not be able to freaking talk
it took you a second to get those no it
took me exactly how long it should have
taken which is hey
um you know what I'm kidding I hope your
teeth fall out
yeah so that's my study corner I love
learning about dreams if you guys want
to look up any dreams go on Dream
Dictionary because I think it's really
interesting to you guys that was
Sophia's studies we're testing out this
new segment if you guys like it let us
know we'll do another study no we're
gonna do another study oh okay
regardless if you like it or not I want
to but you know what Sistine I'm just
gonna say it right now because I usually
do my studies and I talk about dating
and all that stuff and like what guys
would like more with like red lips and
black clothing but I kind of was like
you know what let's just kind of let's
change it up a little bit we're talking
about dating yeah we're elevating as a
podcast we're getting more serious so
we're talking about dreams but next week
we're doing the red nail Theory
oh yeah that actually do you believe in
that 100 so if you don't know what red
nail theory is red nail theory is
apparently when girls wear red nails you
get more uh attention from male because
males men growing up were used to seeing
older
women figures in their life like their
teacher or their mom wearing red nails
and that's where it came from I used to
have a math teacher that had different
length Nails she was my calculus teacher
it was no geometry teacher and it was
horrible I had an artist excuse me so
mad that had a pet squirrel with one
eyeball I remember her yeah and the
score you couldn't pet the score because
it was me mean squirrel yeah she carried
it in a cage so we you know how much we
love conspiracy theories yes you guys
actually have been asking
I don't know actually if you've been
asking conspiracy theories where do they
go yeah this week we've had some DMS yes
thank you this week I decided I'm gonna
list a bunch of very reputable
conspiracies that I found on Reddit and
Tick Tock and we will decide whether
they are true or not rapid fire yeah
number one yeah I'm just gonna blow your
guys's Minds
what if stars are cameras from Aliens
and we are a zoo or experiment
okay can I counter it
I mean I guess okay the reason why I
don't think that's true is because I
think that why would aliens
who are if they're out there
tremendously smarter than us why would
they care to analyze
us who are thousands of thousands of
years back than we need to be or what
else would they do they probably have a
lot of things they can do otherwise so
we don't believe that one number two
it's like Truman Show I like this one
what if oxygen is actually poisonous and
it takes 70 to 100 years to affect us
thank you
oh so like a controlled yeah I think
that's
it is that real yeah yeah
see what if it's actually poisonous and
everyone dies within 70 to 100 years
um I believe that one you know I just
thought about this what if aliens are
Sim controllers
think about it what if you know how he
said we're in a simulation
your study
let me conspiracy right now okay so our
oxygen is killing us what's next what
you just settled is number four anyway
so keep your pie hole shut Jesus
yes oxygen is killing us do you believe
it yeah well I can't talk we believe
Oxygen's killing us okay that's kind of
crazy
number three
I like this one what if every time you
hear that voice in your head telling you
not to do something it's your future
self warning you because they already
know the outcome
nah so you don't believe there's like a
future oh never mind that's all right
two complex why I mean I have a lot of
deja vu maybe it's like my uh future
self recumbing back my body yeah oh oh
see whoa wait
take it back actually you know I take it
back that's what Deja Vu is it's our uh
our future song jumping back in telling
us like
maybe our future self just knew we were
going to say that at the same time
so I think my future self as ditched me
I was not happy with you number four
what if our life is a video game and
every time you start a new year you
start a new level as the game progresses
the levels get harder those who die have
completed the game
think about it the older you get the
more you're faced with
being a kid is super easy
bullying what level is that yeah job
career mortgage relationships death
taxes tax evasion prison there's two
things you can't avoid death and tax
okay
do we believe this
I just think maybe this is more of a
metaphor you know yes yeah I got no I
don't think it's this Theory but it's a
metaphor in the future I definitely
believe in this last one yeah okay your
birthmark is actually a clue of how you
died in your past life the location of
your mark is where you got hurt and died
see I have a birthmark on the inside of
my butt cheek so what does that saying
about my dad no it's a scene remember we
both discovered that we both had this we
have matching birthmarks yeah we do so
how would you do we died maybe we both
died the same way maybe we were friends
in a past life maybe we sat on a
porcupine Ah that's like we wouldn't die
of that well that's interesting okay
that was my conspiracy corner I think
Sophia ruined it no I didn't yeah you
did why I can make comments
[Music]
people are probably thinking the same
thing I'm thinking I'm just the I'm just
the listener which one did you believe
the most I think the oxygen one
for sure
the actual yeah that one that only got
me convinced a little bit I don't
believe in the last one
the Stars the aliens I think that kind
of combines with number four a little
bit but I do think that um Deja Vu is us
being like what if Deja Vu is us being
rebooted because the aliens are trying
to control us with simulation it's like
a reboot like they're logging back in
I'm gonna piggyback off that have you
ever seen those videos on YouTube about
how stars are hinting at the Illuminati
that they sold their soul actually it's
crazy David dobrik just came out with
this video that he had his girlfriend I
saw him come over and that this guy was
part of the Illuminati and said that in
order to join to be a singer an actress
whatever you want to be to be wildly
successful you have to sacrifice a loved
one or someone in your life
and that she was crying and all this
crap if you look up this compilation on
YouTube it's some of the biggest
celebrities like cardi B and Angelina
Jolie uh Jimmy
Jim Carrey believes in it right and you
see them like short circuit for a second
which just reminded me of your Deja Vu
thing do you think this is where lizard
people come from
why you gotta bring lizard people into
this right now well because the biggest
people are lizard people
remember how that conspiracy theory had
before yeah we gotta wrap this show up
we are doing an unsolicited advice if
you guys want your questions to be
answered on the show make sure you go to
our Apple podcast page give us five
stars and leave your question in the
ratings and review section that is the
only way we are going to answer it okay
it is from man's mads I mean oh it's I
think probably like Mandy Amanda s like
whatever man's
um favorite podcast I love listening to
Sophia and Sistine so much it makes me
feel like I'm one of their friends and
sisters and they always write my day you
are see love you even as chaotic as
their shows are oh it's basically like a
like a chance like a kitchen table
conversation for unsolicited advice I
have a question how do you make new
friends I'm graduated from college and
I'm in my early 20s but I always am
looking to make new friends but feel
like it can be really daunting okay
thank you love you both
love this question it stuck out to me
because I feel like I can relate so
heavily yes you can relate to you about
it's hard making new friends I can tell
you how to because I've finally ex like
figured out how to do it after college I
think you have the best of both worlds
with this answer yeah someone that went
to college found College friends and
someone who didn't go to college and
didn't get the opportunity to meet that
new people so literally starting from
Ground Zero trying to meet friends
what I have to say is I would constantly
kick myself being like I have no friends
I don't do this I don't do that but I
also am not reaching out to people I'm
not asking people for their number when
I first meet them I'm not putting myself
out there so No One's Gonna spoon feed
you to meet friends is what I've
realized the hard way and yeah you just
have to push yourself try to reach out
to people that you wouldn't typically
like you maybe had a good time with them
don't know them that well and get dinner
and see where it goes just put yourself
in situations that set you up for
meeting new people because it's not
going to come just fall on your lap
that's good no I completely agree with
that and to go off of that
um a lot of the times like I have
college friends and I get it because a
lot of them when you're grown in college
like they go back to their hometowns
they could be across the country
somewhere else and then you know also
when you leave College you guys change
in your lives like people are in
different situations with their
boyfriends or their family or their
career and so you know it's kind of
interesting when you see someone out of
college like your worlds can be
different so you're thinking okay I need
to make friends that are more aligned to
what's going on in my life right now
um and like to go off what Sistine said
like putting yourself in those positions
and for example like I actually just met
up with a girlfriend last night that I
didn't meet through college and I met
through a workout class and I'd go to
her workout classes a lot and if we're
the same age and it we ended up talking
and I think what the first step needs to
be is like you going up to someone and
talking to them yeah if there's someone
you're seeing frequently at
you're the cafe you always go to maybe
it's if you're studying acting you're
going acting classes maybe it's like
workout class whatever it is that you go
to often
and you think this person has like a
really nice energy to them and they're
open like it doesn't hurt to try it's
like dude I mean if you think about it
if someone came up to you and said hey
how are you it's nice would you be so
weirded out by that person or would you
be really flattered and happy they did
that or even say like someone would like
if you did that too like it's yeah just
do what makes you feel good yeah you can
just say like oh this workout cause it's
hard right like you don't have to be all
like diving in and it it's also 100
senior right reaching out to those
friends that you were considering or you
or maybe you met through a college
friend that like lives in the area
it's yeah you know it is like dating but
it is scary I get where you're coming
from but don't don't let that stop you
from meeting new people either because
that's just a temporary form of
anxiousness and you don't need to live
like that yeah I don't either so work on
it together
okay I think that's it for this episode
thank you guys so much for tuning in to
another episode of the unwax podcast and
we will see you next Tuesday adios
[Music]